hearing the game of thrones opening
theme for the house of dragon which is
absolutely beautiful i had the biggest
smile on my face and just had chills
like honestly it was quite nostalgic
here in it now some people were
complaining that they wanted to hear a
new theme for this opening but i gotta
disagree cuz you know when you have such
an epic theme why not just reuse it and
having an original theme just makes the
show more familiar and keeps that
nostalgic element that we had for the
first time watching game of thrones also
especially considering george r martin
wants game of thrones to be like star
wars and marvel in the sense of them
release and many other projects that are
all connected together and most of the
star wars and marvel openings are
similar but what do you guys think do
you think they should have made a
completely new theme for this opening or
are you glad they used the same one let
me know in the comment section below and
if you haven't already please do
consider subscribing to the channel
thanks for watching guys